نقلت القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه سماعا
انفجارات قرب مدينه حيفا نتيجه اعتراض
الدفاعات الجويه لطائره مسيره اطلقت من
لبنان بعد سمع دوي صفاره الانذار في عكا
وخليج حيفا وافاد مراسل الجزيره بان
طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه شنت غارات على
بلده راميا ومحيطها في القطاع الاوسط من
جنوب لبنان وقالت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان سلاح الجو شن هجوما استباقيا جنوب
لبنان واستهدف بنيه تحتيه لحزب الله كان
حزب الله قد اطلق امس 80 صاروخا باتجاه
مواقع وتجمعات ومستوطنات اسرائيليه قباله
الحدود اللبنانيه كما اعلن الحزب تنفيذ ست
هجمات من بينها استهداف مستوطنه كارات
شموه ب 30 صاروخ كتيوشا وقال الحزب انه
هاجم بالطائرات المسيره والصواريخ الموجهه
وال فعيه تجمعات اسرائيليه في مزارع شبع
المحتله كما استهدف مواقع في محيط الموقع
البحري براس الناقوره